Guten Tag, ich bin Dr. Matt. Ich bin zuständiger als für Sie. Ich möchte mit Ihnen über Ihre Bescheidung sprechen.
Aber so als bräuchte ich ein paar persönlichen Daten. Dann sprechen wir genau über Ihre Bescheidung.
Wie lautet Ihr Name?
Mein Name ist Hahn. Sandra Hahn.
Sandra. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamenbuch stabilieren?
Haar wie Heinrich, A wie Anton, Haar wie Heinrich, N wie North Pole.
Und Vornahmepintern?
Sandra. S-A-N-D-R-A.
Herr Hahn, ja?
Frau Hahn.
Herr Frau Hahn, Entschuldigung.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Frau Hahn?
Ich bin 30 Jahre alt. Ich bin 1993 geboren.
30 Jahre alt? Ja.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren? Könnten Sie wieder holen?
Am 1. August 1993.
90, ok. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 68 Kilogramm schwer.
68 Kilogramm schwer?
Und wiege bin 1 Meter 72 groß?
1 Meter 72 groß, ja.
Ok, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Bescheid haben Sie, Frau Hahn?
Also ich bin jetzt ungefähr seit einem Monat schon sehr unruhig.
Und ich habe Durchfall.
Und manchmal habe ich Fieber.
Manchmal habe ich Herzrasen.
Und ich bin sehr schnell gereizt.
Und manchmal habe ich Bluthochdruck.
Manchmal zittert meine Hand.
Haben Sie Haarausfall auch?
Ja, ein bisschen, aber Haarausfall habe ich schon immer gehabt.
Sind die Bescheid-Weiden live-samer oder philosophisch auf die Trete?
Also das habe ich jetzt schon seit ungefähr 2 Monaten, aber jetzt in den letzten 3 Wochen zunehmend.
Ich habe viel mehr Durchfall und sonst.
Und mein Partner hat auch gesagt, dass ich sehr aggressiv bin, manchmal sehr unruhig bin.
Ok.
Haben Sie auch Brückianager bemerkt?
Bitte was?
Haben Sie Blutschupuren im Schuttel bemerkt?
Blut?
Ja.
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Wie viel mal müssten Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Ja, so einen Tag, 3-4 Mal.
3-4 Mal.
Ok.
Ist Ihnen übel, müssten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, gar nicht.
Das wundert mich auch, warum ich Durchfall habe, aber keine Beschwerden habe, so Übelkeit oder so, oder Bauchschmerzen.
Ok.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie pfiebig fühlen.
Ja, ich habe es nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich so ein bisschen, als wenn mir warm wird.
Ist es so, dass Sie sich übergeben?
Ja, so ein bisschen, als wenn mir warm wird.
Ist Ihnen warme Unverzweglichkeit bekannt?
Wie bitte?
Wärme in Toleranz, Wärme in Unverzweglichkeit.
Eigentlich nicht.
Ok.
Schwitzeln Sie oft?
Nein, eigentlich, es geht.
Manchmal nicht so oft, normal, würde ich sagen.
Ok.
Haben Sie folgte Hände bemerkt?
Manchmal, ja, manchmal habe ich das.
Ok.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden schon gehabt, oder das ist erst mal ich aufgetreten?
Also das habe ich ja zum ersten Mal so, das ist, bin auch sehr besorgt, was das sein könnte.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie Krebs habe oder so.
Nein, nein, bitte denken Sie den nicht schlimmsten.
Es gibt salreiche Krankheiten, die ähnlich oder gleiche Beschwerden hervorrufen.
Bitte machen Sie bitte keine Sorge.
Weil ich habe nämlich auch Gewichtsverlust.
Ich habe jetzt ungefähr 3 kg Gewichtsverlust, obwohl ich normalerweise gut esse.
Kann das nicht doch irgendwie kregen?
Das ist vielleicht so ein, dass ich von meiner Arbeit über die Mutter saub gestorben habe.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass das eventuell Krebs war.
Die hat obwohl Bauspeichendosen.
Aber machen Sie bitte keine Sorge.
Es gibt salreiche Ursachen, die Gewichtsverlust verursachen.
Ok.
Wir sind für Sie, wir sind deswegen für Sie da.
Dann machen Sie bitte keine Sorge.
Wie viele Kilogramm haben Sie abgenommen?
Ungefähr 3 Kilo Herz.
Ihn?
Ja, in den letzten 4 Wochen jetzt.
4 Wochen, 3 Kilo Herz.
Aber Appetit ist gut, ja? Appetit ist gut.
Ja, ich schon, das hat sich nicht schämmert.
Ist die Störgank oder was auch so?
Ich schuldige, weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich meine, er weiß auch das nicht.
Da habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Ok.
Schlaufen Sie gut?
Ja, unruhig manchmal.
Also unruhig.
Aber eigentlich ganz gut.
Ok, Frau Hahn, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Noch habe ich, nee, eigentlich nicht.
Also das ist das Hauptsächliche.
Ich habe auch keine Bauchschmerz oder so was.
Aber warum habe ich diesen Durchfall?
Das macht mich ein bisschen unruhig.
Sie haben keine Bauchschmerzen.
Sie haben nur Durchfall, ja?
Genau.
Aber warum?
Ich habe doch auch nicht, ich esse in den Probiotika ein.
Und trotzdem wird das nicht besser.
Ich kann verstehen.
Ich werde, wer führen jetzt nur beim Emleensgespräch durch.
Ich werde auch ein paar Untersuchungen noch führen.
Während die alle Erkenntnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Meinen Sie genau, dass es gar nicht schlimm muss sein?
Eigentlich, tatsächlich kann ich Ihnen nicht genau sagen,
wie jetzt momentan, was Sie haben.
Aber ich habe verdacht auch Schilddrösen überfunktionen.
Das ist sehr gut behandelt war.
Bitte bitte.
Ist das nicht gefährlich?
Die Schilddröse ist doch ein wichtiges Organ, oder?
Ja, ja, das ist wichtiges Organ.
Aber das ist sehr behandelt war.
Ich werde je nach Ergebnis ein paar Medikamente verschreiben.
Oder ich werde auch ein paar Untersuchen gehen, war anders.
Und Sie meinen, das ist nicht Krebs?
Nein, Krebs ist eher momentan unwahrscheinlich.
Aber wenn die alle Erkenntnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen genau sagen.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Hahn, nun möchte ich mit Ihnen über Ihr folgeschiedes sprechen.
Davor möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Leiden Sie an irgendetwas vorerkrankungen?
Nein, gar nicht, ich habe gar nichts.
Nehmen Sie Ihre irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich habe auch Profil manchmal, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Ich glaube 400.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Meine Mandeln sind aus.
Mandeln?
Wann wurde dabei Ihnen diese Operation durchgeführt?
Ich war 10 Jahre alt.
2003 oder 2002?
Mit 10 Jahren.
Was ist die Operation?
Ja.
Sind Sie ausländisch operiert worden?
Nein.
Wurden Sie schon mal stationär aufgenommen?
Ja, wegen der Mandeln-Operation.
Ausländisch?
Sind Sie gegen COVID-19 so wie Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ich denke schon, ja.
Okay, das ist cool.
Sind bei Ihnen alle gehenbekannt?
Nein.
Eine letzte Zeit habe ich schon das Gefühl,
dass wenn ich die Milch nicht vertragen würde.
Aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Die Ausgleichs-Krise.
Die haben so Blähungen, Bauchschmerzen,
Wieder Durchfall.
Okay, Frau Hahn,
könntest du mir bitte sagen, ob Sie rauchlich sind?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Manchmal, ja, im Wochenende.
Was trinken Sie?
Cocktails und Wein.
Manchmal.
Ich muss fragen, ob Sie Konzentren haben.
Bestrugen einnehmer?
Ja.
Ich nehme keinen Rogen ein.
Okay, das ist schon ein Rücken.
Was ist Ihr Familienstadt?
Ich habe ein Partner.
Aber Mama, sind Sie ledig?
Ich bin nicht ein Feierer, aber wir leben zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Was sind Sie von Bebrun?
Ich bin beruhigend.
Leiden Sie unter Peh-Stress?
Ich bin stresslos.
Ich gehe gerne arbeiten.
Okay, das ist gut.
Gibt es in der Familie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Ich kann verstehen.
Haben Sie Bruder?
Ich habe Geschwister, ein Schwester und ein Bruder.
Aber ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Okay, Frau Hahn, das war meine Frage.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Fragen?
Oder machten Sie etwas für Sie?
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe eine Schilddrüse erkannt.
Ist das eine Schilddrüse?
Ich habe keine Schilddrüse.
Es gibt zahlerweiche Krankheiten,
die gleich oder ähnlicher Pech werden verursachen.
Ich werde ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich kann Ihnen, ob Sie irgendwelche Krebs haben.
Aber er kann.
Ist das eine Schilddrüse?
Es gibt immer eine Möglichkeit.
Aber das ist eher unwahrscheinlich.
Muss ich denn heute hier bleiben?
Oder kann ich wieder nach Hause?
Ich muss ja nicht im Kleinkernhaus bleiben.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen und Blut abnehmen.
Ich veranlaufe auch einfach Untersuchungen.
Okay.
Was soll ich jetzt meinem
Freund sagen?
Ich muss hier bleiben?
Oder kann ich wieder nach Hause?
Ich will auch wissen, was ich habe.
Sie müssen im MinDSense 2 oder 3 Stunden im Kleinkernhaus bleiben.
Wenn ich die alle Ergebnisse gesehen habe,
kann ich Ihnen sagen,
wie lange im Kleinkernhaus bleiben müssen.
Ist das damit tablettenbehandelbar?
Oder muss ich etwas machen?
Was passiert dann?
Wie schon gesagt habe,
muss ich die Ergebnisse der Untersuchungen sehen.
Dann kann ich entscheiden,
ob ich eine Medikamente oder andere Massnahmen fürführen kann.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Schilddrüse ist hier, wo ist die Schilddrüse überhaupt?
Ja, die Schilddrüse befinden sich im Haus.
Das Hausbereich ist zuständig für unser Metabolismus.
Diese Schilddrüse organisiert unser Metabolismus.
Wie funktioniert es?
Oder langsam funktioniert es?
Was habt ihr denn da?
Ich habe das hier im Kleinkern,
das ist das Schilddrüse, das ist das Schilddrüse.
Das ist das Schilddrüse, das ist das Schilddrüse.
Was habt ihr denn da,
die Schilddrüse mit meinem Bauch zu tun
und mit meinem Stuhlkern zu tun?
Das ist das, was ich...
Nicht, dass das vom Bauch ist?
Ja, ich kann verstehen.
Schilddrüse hat viele Aufgaben
und Schilddrüse organisiert viele
innere Organe
und deswegen
diese Schilddrüse
schüttert Troide-Hormonen,
bzw. Styrusen-Hormonen im Blut aus,
auf diese Weise kontrolliert unsere
alle Metabolismus und innere Organe.
Okay, verstanden.
Ja, habe ich noch nie etwas von gehört.
Danke.
Was haben Sie denn gemacht?
Ja, die haben wir gemacht.
Danke schön.
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Was haben Sie denn gemacht?
Aufklären.
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Metabolismus, was bedeutet Metabolismus?
Das ist perfekt.
Ich möchte zwei Fragen.
Die Diagnose ist eindeutig.
Deswegen
erst mal hatten Sie einen Unfall,
Kopfunfall oder andere
und haben Sie
letztes
in der Erdbeutelung
eine Erdbeutelung
oder eine Kontrast-
oder Kompetuitomografie
oder
eine Kontrast- oder Kompetuitomografie
oder eine Kontrast-
und diese Fragen fühlen Sie sich warm,
wenn die Weta
kalter ist.
Wärme und Verzehklichkeit
haben Sie?
Nein,
Wärme und Verzehklichkeit
oder diese Frage
ich denke
ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Unglaublich vielleicht.
Ich habe auch zwei Fragen.
Anme Selva
Ich habe
keine Verdickung im Hals gemerkt. Ich habe keine Schluckbeschwerden.
Ja. Ich möchte auch das fragen, aber dann ich habe Teilgesen.
Ich habe auch keine Bemerkungen an meinen Augen gemerkt.
Ich habe auch nicht gemerkt. Ich habe nicht gefragt, aber ich habe es auch nicht bemerkt.
Während der Annäßigesprich möchte auch diese Frage stellen, aber da in
den Lauf des Annäßigespriches vergessen.
Da dürfen Sie nicht vergessen.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe keine Schluckbeschwerden. Ich habe auch keine Schmerzen,
kein Druck. Das ist alles keine Verdickung gemerkt, weil ich zu 20
U-Bots fragen sollte.
Können wir erst als Geschenk beginnen?
Natürlich.
Bitte schön.
Wir haben eine neue Patientin, Sandra Hahn.
Ich würde über Sie berichten. Darf ich?
Natürlich.
Frau Hahn ist 30 Jahre alt, 1,72 m groß, 68 kg schwer.
Sie steht heute bei uns wegen seit ein Monaten Bestellhänder und
zunehmend ein Innerer Unruhe, Nervosität,
2 Monate, erst mal, nicht 1, 2 Monate.
2 Monate.
Bitte nochmal, bitte wegen.
Sie stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit 2 Monaten Bestellhänder und
zunehmender Nervosität in der Unruhe,
sowie die Erröhre vor.
Außerdem ist bei ihr die folgende Begleitstimmung aufgefallen.
Tafikade, Tremor der Hände, Allopätsi,
feuchte Hände,
Polyphagie sowie Gewichtsverlust von 3 kg in 4 Wochen.
Laut der Patientin sind die Beschwerden langsam und
erstmalig aufgetreten.
Die Fragen nach Neuser, MSI und Bauchschmerzen,
wurden dran gehalten.
Die vegetative Anämnese ist unauffällig.
Die Vorerkrankungen sind auch unauffällig.
Sie nimmt über 4500 mg Beipedorf.
Sie ist mit 10 Jahren bei ihr,
und sie ist mit 10 Jahren mit dem Beipedorf gehalten.
Sie ist mit einem Geigenkronik-Norwitzung,
sowie Kinderkrankheiten geimpft.
Sie ist mit 10 Jahren mit dem Beipedorf geimpft.
Alle Regen sind bei ihr verneint.
Laktosinterluranz ist bei ihr bekannt, diese Interluranz
äußert sich mit Metrorismus, Bauchschmerzen und Diarrheur.
Frau Hanh raucht nicht.
Sie trinkt Cocktail oder Wein.
Frau Hanh drogt und konsumiert der Verneint.
Sie ist ledig.
Sie lebt mit ihrem Partner zusammen.
Sie ist Bürokrauffahrer von Beruf.
Die Familie in einem Nese ist unauffällig.
Herr Minister, haben wir gefragt?
Nein.
Eine Schwangerschaft gefragt?
Was hat die Patientin beim Hausarzt?
Was hat sie zuletzt?
Das habe ich nicht gefragt.
Aber während der Untersuchung werde ich fragen.
Es ist wichtig zu fragen, ob eine Budedersuchung gemacht wurde.
Sie ist schon 30 Jahre alt.
Was haben Sie denn von der Verdachtdiagnose?
Die Analystische Angabe der Analystische Angabe
ist auf einer hypertroyose Hintdifferenz.
Sie ist auch mit Schutur, Marmalitna und Panikattacken.
Sie hat keine psychische Erkrankung.
Nein.
Wie können Sie das beweisen, ob sie eine hypertroyose Hintdifferenz hat?
Ich werde erst die Körperkontrolle suchen, dann Blut abnehmen.
Danach veranstalte ich oder führe ich Ultraschall durch.
Ultraschall von?
Ultraschall von Schittröse.
Mit Hilfe Blutbild kann ich beschütten, ob die Patient hypertroyose hat.
Was ist der Grund für eine hypertroyose Hintdifferenz?
Es gibt z.B. saarlöse Erkrankheiten.
Schutur, Marmalitna, Entsündung der Schittröse oder Autoimmun,
Autoimmun, Schittröse, Erkrankung, oder übermäßig, jotkonsum.
Schittrösenknoten?
Schittrösenknoten, ja, Autonom.
Genau, gibt es auch noch.
Was machen Sie, wenn Sie festgestellt haben, dass sie hypertroyose hat?
Ich werde erst Ultraschall durchführen, wenn es keine wichtige Befunde hat.
Verabreiche ich Statika, z.B. Kalbimosor, Matimosor oder Propyto-Urosil.
Wenn es ein paar Knoten gibt, dann veranstalte ich Synthekrapie.
Lassen Sie die Patienten hier oder schicken Sie sie nach Hause?
Ja, nach Untersuchung.
Was wäre ein Grund, im Krankenhaus zu lassen?
Wenn die Patienten erhöhte Blubdruck hat, dann müssen wir...
Nein, andere.
Ja, erhöhte Blubdruck.
Tachikates z.B.
Tachikates.
Und wenn sie auch instabil wird, z.B.
Troetoxysiakris.
Ganz genau.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Dann muss man die Patienten auf die Überwachungsstation nehmen.
Dann muss man mit Cortisonen und so etwas behandeln.
Aber das haben wir auch noch immer.
Die Patientin hat ja auch Ihnen erzählt, dass sie Herzblasen hat.
Ja, Tachikates.
Da muss man auch ein Wetterblocker geben, wenn sie nach Hause möchte.
Man muss auf jeden Fall anraten, dass sie sich zeitnah beim Hausarzt vorstellt.
Der Hausarzt muss die Medikamente aufschreiben
und regelmäßig kontrollend Schildkrötenhormone machen.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Ja.
Was Sie auch ausschließen,
müssen Sie vielleicht auch, ob Sie eventuell ein Karzinom hat.
Ja.
Das müssen Sie auch ausschließen, mit dem Blutparameter
und dem Unterscheid.
Ob das ein Karzinom sein könnte.
Ja, Per.
Ja, absolut.
Das war nur eine Aussage.
Ja.
Wenn Sie aber nur milde Symptome haben, also nicht so Tachikates,
dann kann man diese Patienten auch in Ruhe nach Hause wieder entlassen,
dass der Hausarzt weiter behandelt
oder der Endokrinologe sie weiter behandelt zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Aber in Deutschland ist es immer sehr schwer,
ein Termin beim Endokrinologen zu bekommen.
Da wird man sehr viel, die Monate meistens kommt auf einen, wo man lebt
und dann muss man dann schauen,
dass man die Patienten auf jeden Fall therapiert.
Sie sollte nicht untherapiert gelassen.
Welche Laborwerte in Deutschland im Notfall
sind die Patienten auf jeden Fall durchführen?
Auf jeden Fall TSA, FT3, FT4.
Das muss man auf jeden Fall abnehmen.
Ich würde auch normalerweise,
wenn die Patienten jetzt stationär bleiben sollte
und wir einen Verdacht,
einen Knoten gesehen haben,
dann würde ich auf jeden Fall auch das Türi-Bibin-Bindes-Hormon machen.
Also die Tür-Bibin-Antikörper
und natürlich auch die Schilddrüßel-Antikörper,
die habe ich vergessen zu sagen,
Trak- und TPO zum Beispiel.
Aber im stationär Therapie,
im stationär Beantlung.
Genau.
Das würde ich stationär machen,
wenn Sie sagen, man kann diese Patienten aufnehmen
und dann kann man sie antherapieren.
Wenn sie stabil ist, kann man einen Brief schreiben
und sagen, morgen zum Hausarzt gehen
und der soll das machen.
Der kann das auch bestimmen.
Dafür muss die Patienten nicht stationär sein.
Stationär muss man sie nur aufnehmen,
wenn sie nicht stabil ist,
wenn sie ein hemodynamisches Problem hat.
U-Truckdruck, Tachikadie,
Hypertämie, weiß ich nicht, irgendwas.
Oder wenn sie auch psychologisch oder nicht gut ist,
wenn sie jetzt irgendwie verwirrt ist oder so etwas,
wenn sie sehr aggressiv ist,
dann muss man sie auch stationär belassen.
Ja.
Ihre Assistenz hat nicht gesagt,
erst mal EKG durchführen.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Bevor man durchführen kann,
kann man EKG durchführen.
Vitalparameter.
Das ist wichtig.
Und Hojam,
dass es gleiche Patienten im Bestalldorf gibt.
Das ist ein sehr ähnliche,
endometriöse,
eine Pille behandelt,
das heißt Minulett.
Und dann eine hypertriöse Symptomatik.
Okay.
Deswegen,
diese Patienten,
ist Frau,
müssen wir genau fragen.
Ich habe eine hausführliche Frage.
Ich denke auch,
dass man vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ob das bei den Prüfungen
gefragt wird, aber man sollte mal fragen,
wann war der letzte Hausbesuch?
Hausarzt besucht.
Hat der Hausarzt schon mal,
oder haben Sie den Hausarzt kontaktiert?
Haben Sie Ihre Beschwerden schon im Hausarzt geschildert?
Hat der schon mal aufgenommen?
Der Hausarzt kennt die Patienten meistens am besten.